capitalism means private losses and
private profits the private it doesn't
mean private profits and socialized
losses all right this is Peter Schiff
and I've come down here to Occupy Wall
Street to represent the 1% and see if I
can have a dialogue with the other 99%
maybe see if we can find some common
ground it's not capitalism that has
failed them it's socialism it's
corporatism it's crony capitalism it's
fascism that is the problem capitalism
is the solution if we can only fully
embrace it anyway we've got a few people
around here and I'm wondering who in
particular would like to address any of
their grievances imagine compassionate
capitalism is this such a thing could
there be such a thing it's the most
compassionate system I know by
definition if you make 100 million
imagine how many jobs could be created
if you just made 50 million but what
you're forgetting is if I make a hundred
million I had to create a lot of jobs to
make that money that's the point when
the capitalist is amazing money who
agreed and the problem with but we're on
we all greedy everybody oh no we're not
well you cannot say that we're all
greedy you cannot well you don't you
want to injure yourself you don't want
more you don't want better thing to
yourself we're all doing that's the
problem
we well some of us are simple people we
just want a place to live we just want
some food in my refrigerator and
capitalism the 10-count
capitalism is the best way to get those
things I mean you're standing here
you're not naked you have clothes on the
people that made those clothes did it to
make a profit and to make a profit they
had to make clothes that you can afford
I think that socialism is wrong it is
wrong it's absolutely wrong first know I
employ I employ 150 people I am boy 150
people right I've created those jobs how
many jobs did you create how many people
do boy
how much money have I given you but you
haven't give me anything but I my point
is I've created 150 jobs I'm calm I'm
writing paychecks every week I haven't
given you anything
what do you let everybody in this park
has contributed to your fat ass later
yeah how do you figure
and one way shady how do you figure that
you know something you need to open up
we might with anyone is partisan but it
on with the people in this part working
20-hour days or at my uncle I started my
company in my in my one-bedroom
apartments were they there no they
weren't
I'm quite sure they have been where do
you stand concerning up light I feel for
your plight I knew these banks were
going to fail I wanted him to fail I
didn't want the government to bail him
out that's not capitalism capitalism
would have let the banks fail a lot of
people on Wall Street would have lost
their jobs if we had capitalism do you
see this as a left-wing movement but is
this more is that populist a political
movement well you know I think that
people especially young people you have
a right to be pissed off you know one of
the what are the problems people want is
the forgiveness of the student loans why
are there all these student loans it's
because the government guaranteed up if
the government minded its own business
then nobody can get a student there's
ever been an awfully without government
involved no but my point is it wasn't
for the government college would be
cheap the tuitions would be low it's
only because the government subsidizes
it and guarantees the loans but who gets
the shaft here it's the kids the
colleges get all the money and they
stick the kids with a bill they graduate
with these worthless degrees with a
hundred thousand or more in debt and
they can't get a job and if they get a
job they're paying massive taxes they're
paying Social Security taxes to support
a generation that voted in this Ponzi
scheme before any of these people were
born they're paying income taxes if
there's anything left they got to pay
back their student loans and they can't
even discharge them in bankruptcy and if
they die their parents are stuck with
them I think it's the corporations that
get greedy and decide that Oh while we
pay someone $8 an hour if we can get
someone for 50 cents an hour in India if
you go back to the 1950s for example
America paid the highest wages in the
world much higher than we do today
yet we produced the cheapest stuff our
products cost less than products produce
anywhere
in the world and so we sold them all
around the world why how was it that we
could pay the highest wages but produced
below his cost up it was because we had
more capital we had more capital because
we had lower taxes and fewer regulations
what do you want to accomplish to
confirm from con Agra philosophy well I
wanted to come down and guess I see a
protest movement and I agree with the
sentiment and I agree with the fact that
you should be protesting it's just my
point is it's Washington that should be
the recipient of the protest you guys
should be marching on the White House
and the Federal Reserve demanding your
freedom back look Steve Jobs just passed
away he made billions how many people
here have iPhones in their pocket I feel
but you know wait you wanted he's not a
humanitarian he's a businessman might be
he enriched the lives of millions of
people pursuing his own son and not a
ramp so that you can do an ollie in
front of your camera I actually want to
have a conversation what the 99% to 1%
meme was just one meme out of many memes
what's with me I'm I'm so sorry
a popular turn of phrase okay so the
catch phrase 99% this is not 99% Park
its Liberty Plaza and the 99% catch
phrase is not definitive of everyone
here it makes sense why a popularity
meme would be popular I understand you
have to make money but there's gotta be
regulations because I believe in
democracy
but I also believe in regulations the
market has to grow at a sensible rate
right you cannot grow too fast if the
market goes too fast they will crash see
the regulation we want is the market
that's the regulation that works the
same thing is with labor a corporation
just can't take advantage of its workers
and came as little as it wants because
businesses compete with one another to
buy labor did a corporation and slavery
what did the government do it well the
corporation what does slavery have to do
with what we're talking about we're
saying we're saying with there there is
a role for government in our society
incorporation I do
but slavery was wrong to begin with so
let's not even it was government that
created government is there to protect
property life liberty and that's it
you mentioned Walmart so what are you
afraid that Walmart's gonna do you what
am I afraid that is what is Walmart you
go and ask the employees that are
working in sweatshop type conditions
that don't get enough doors that don't
have healthcare
how is it then why don't they quit I
mean Walmart doesn't hold a gun to their
head if if they can get it better
general so why did the rape victim get
raped who was she doing out late at
night do you want to go back to 1920
1930 what is this golden year I don't
want a humble kids want to go back to I
don't want what here the 60s the 70s I
don't hear I don't want to go back to
that technology but I want to go back to
that level of freedom I want go left it
was more Vallejo for everybody vote at
some point I'll african-americans in I
know there's had the one about telling
you you want to go back there look we
don't want to go I'm telling you there's
more there's more economic freedom is
more economic yes a lot more
shoe freedom and social justice there's
been memorials for Steve Jobs all over
the place at every Apple store every
every there's reporters that are all
around the world that never asked one
single question to Steve Jobs when he
was alive
why are you manufacturing your iPhone in
China and you don't have any of your
manufacturing and I tell you why because
we may think that's fair to the American
people be quick the American people
don't own those jobs
Steve Jobs has a right to manufacture
where he wants he does and right to do
it and the problem is we have made it
too expensive for him the manufacturing
we did art we the government can workers
and want too much oh the government put
too much always the guy gets remember
the reason that content that employer
employers right want to lower wages is
because their customers want low prices
everybody in this park wants low prices
you can't have low prices we don't know
we do you believe that the federal
government has a right to exist in to
governor lives if it has the right to
exist but not in the form it exists
today is it's operating outside the EPA
should be disbanded I think it does a
lot more harm than good
do you believe the NFPA should be dead
I'd like to get rid of it what about the
FDA um the board I take the board of
education we should I want about the
Board of Education I want to get rid of
the entire federal department education
yeah it is wasting our money and it is
running on the cost of education sure
what I've learned for three let me
finish what I've learned over the years
is to never argue with a fool and you my
friend or fool okay so all right Lewis
right so I just stumbled into you stall
oh my well I run all these messages how
did you say how could you defend the EPA
and APA in sort of agitation because I
look it's not the border education
you're talk about this farmer but you
did I call you ACS do I call you an
idiot no you didn't all right thirty
percent of the homeless people in
America are veterans so when everybody
says let we support the troops that's a
lot you support the troops when they're
out there getting killed or shot but
when they come home and they're homeless
and they got no jobs you don't support
the true I didn't even and that's why I
didn't even support a lot of these Wars
and put those troops over there in the
first place let me find a cure all right
you're saying you against the federal
government you want it to change in all
that but you guys are the ones or at
least these guys on Wall Street are the
ones that are funding all the campaigns
and putting these people in power in the
first place right but and then you do so
because you know that they will enact
policies that you want and then you also
know that once they do that and you
become friends with them through
campaign fundraising and all that that
is the problem you that they will let
you in the government you'll be like hey
can I can I be Secretary of the Treasury
if they had no power there'd be no
lobbying they'd have me there'd be
nothing to give out we don't want the
government to be able to pick winners
and losers just say you get a bailout
and you don't you get you pay attacks
and you get a subsidy that is the
problem did you know that for years I
was on television writing books warning
about all the things that have just
happened I warned about the housing
bubble I warned that was going to crash
no well I can't I could I tried I'd no
one knows people don't listen to me in
Washington you're talking about
glass-steagall the reason that we had
glass-steagall was to counteract the
damage of government insured bank
accounts wait do you have a bank account
yes that Bank do you care what the bank
does with your money when you deposited
there do you care about the loans I do
why do you worry in the gamble with it
if the bank Gamble's with their money
and loses does it affect your deposit of
course it does how it's concerned by the
government if you think I'll tell people
they you nobody nobody in this area that
has a bank account has ever looked at
the bank's portfolio to see what kind of
loans they're making nice
what wouldn't you like to get into the
one for now yeah you don't want more
money you don't if I offer to put you in
the one for right now you're Fredo and I
would pay my share and get rid of okay
I'm really what do you mean give me ask
you a question
haha oh no Jerry what will they ask you
questions yes so that these follow them
pay their studios but get off of food
stamps could be successful for just like
you what are you driving well they don't
have a car I pay much more than thirty
five percent of my tour link on second
tax what are you thinking less than me
and I employed her well Buffett is full
of it because Warren Buffett is the
biggest shareholder in Berkshire
Hathaway so he's paying a 35% tax on his
profits I am giving the government half
of what I earn do you think they should
take more I think we should get rid of
the Bush tax cuts first of all we should
get rid of the corporate income tax
because corporations don't pay taxes
either their workers pay taxes their
customers pay the tax or their
shareholders and a lot of the
shareholders are elderly people who are
trying to live off their retirement same
people taxes no tax people on the
individual the corporate level is a ruse
they're not paying the taxes they're
passing them on New Zealand then for me
to stay here and go to cook you know
what if the government stopped
subsidizing student loans that the
universities would have to slash the
prices and then you can afford to go you
wouldn't need a loan okay thank you for
the answer do you believe that breckman
Delano Roosevelt did what he had to do
in 1939 government intervention
oh he caused the Great Depression yes by
doing exactly what Herbert Hoover did
he's ruled of Wall Street Witness crisis
in Europe and you know they paid a big
role Wall Street drank the alcohol that
the Federal Reserve poured but if there
was no Fed pouring the alcohol if Fannie
and Freddie weren't guaranteeing all
these mortgages Wall Street wouldn't
have originated them so it was Wall
Street working with government but the
source of the problem was government
government started that's how come when
I was warning about the crisis back in
2004 and 2005 begging the Fed to raise
interest rates trying to get Fannie and
Freddie out of the mortgage guaranteed
business nobody wanted to listen to them
you know you know what the richest
County is now in the United States
Washington County uh it's now been it's
now wealthier than in Silicon Valley dot
because now it's all the money going to
the bureaucrats they're raising their
pay they're you know all the lobbyists
are getting rich because the government
is doling out all these favors how can
you blame the Huckabee said is just a
federal government when the people that
were in the government like Ronald
Reagan's Secretary of the Treasury was
was Don Regan he was a secretary of the
Treasury then in the claim years there
was a route Secretary of Treasury Rubin
and these guys were a head of Goldman
Sachs but head of Citigroup and so these
are the people that are actually making
these quite economic Weber I agree with
you on this I want to get Wall Street's
influence out of Washington this is
about what why would II wouldn't so when
you're talking about you know
businessmen your your lumping everybody
in the same category as Goldman Sachs
and JP Morgan and Morgan Stanley they're
not free but I believe you're stuck on
the synecdoche of Wall Street it doesn't
matter that it's Wall Street are because
we're protesting here it's still done
with some way everywhere the rap on this
movement is that it's anti-capitalist
anti-business that it's that you guys
are all walking around with copies of
the communist manifesto in your pocket
all right well clear no I've seen so
many Ron Paul supporters and
libertarians here you'd be surprised
be something libertarian yourself
eighteen members of the Federal Reserve
Board they have connections to the
Federal Reserve are sitting right now on
companies that receive part of the seven
hundred billion dollar chart fail that's
what about the the conflict of interest
that exists between Wall Street and the
Federal Reserve your hundred-percent
right it's a disgrace you know when I
was on television when they first
proposed I was against tarp I said look
if there's a bank that is going to fail
you'll let it fail you'll let the
shareholders lose money
let the bondholders lose money because
if you bail them out now it's a moral
hazard and we're just going to get more
of that bad behavior in the future you
know capitalism means private losses and
private profits the private it doesn't
mean private profits and socialized
losses banks are keeping interest rates
artificially low to prop up the
speculative activity on Wall Street what
we actually need in this country is
higher interest rates not lower interest
rates because that'll take the money out
of Wall Street put it back on Main
Street
businessmen can't borrow money at these
low entry
traits I think if you're making more
than two million dollars I think that's
when I we had the biggest growth in the
economy is when it discouraged
millionaires from paying themselves huge
bonuses they reinvested it back in their
companies they created jobs for the
workers and instead they sit on their
cash now and they let the rest of us
drown in debt and then sit on the street
and go homeless and it's ridiculous so
you think that I should pay 70 percent
of my income above two million in taxes
yes you think next dollar should be
taxed at 70 ok so if that's the deal you
know what I would do
once my income got to 2 million I would
stop working for the rear I would
furlough my employees and say you know
what I've made my limit I'm not going to
work for 30 cents on the dollar I'm
playing golf I'm going fishing I'll see
you next February how about that how
could how come how come that didn't
apply in the 1970s and 1960s nobody paid
those taxes back then you know how many
I would much rather and he was booming
when you're effective hits you because
no one paid those high taxes correlation
with the national debt and the lowering
of the effective tax rate and the
wealthiest people in this country you're
not fooling anybody no sir I'm also a 1%
and I think you're making us look really
bad how do you figure because I think
you're just coming your facts are wrong
your logic is wrong I might get into a
long discussion but I don't think that
you're helping my facts aren't wrong but
as a member the one percent what do you
think you want do you think your taxes
should be raised yes I do what percent
of your income do you pay in taxes 10
percent how would you like to pay 50
percent like me I would oh really well
then why not write a bigger check when
you pay your taxes instead of paying 10
percent I would be very I think well no
one's stopping you from paying more
taxes yeah and for many many many years
until recent history it was around 70
percent it has only come down from 70
percent over the last 20-30 years yes
nobody actually paid the 70 percent
there were so many loopholes and
deductions I'm glad you're talking but I
think there's a many other
one-percenters who would strongly
disagree with it I can tell you this
most people that make a lot of money
they're not going to work for 30 cents
on the dollar you know people who are
going to work our butts off to keep 30
cents a lot of time in Europe and trust
me there's a lot of people who work very
hard there and margin rates are no
they're not they're not paying those
kind of taxes they're not true
I lived in Europe there are plenty of
people in Europe who believin in
investing in the state in being good
citizens you're shooting American
exceptionalism this American
exceptionalism line that you're some
kind of special cat you're not ma'am you
said you agreed when I when I mentioned
the fact that they're one in the same
wall she and the government is one of
the same and they're not going to change
it from here it has to be changed
legislatively and in the ballot box
because it's all it's because of the
rules and regulations that emanate from
Washington
Wall Street is just trying to get a
piece of that pie no but but the
appearance is that you guys are against
capitalism in business and this is the
symbol that's a tiny minority that those
are the diehard extremists here and
maybe some other people that are not
extremists but are still Pro socialists
or whatever but a lot of I'm willing to
bet the majority of people here are Pro
capitalism I'm Pro capitalism but I
don't think that that means that that's
kind of what I'm thinking that's why I
wanted to come down and clear up these
misunderstandings because the movement
is getting a bad rap I'm my fundamental
point with with you right now is that
you should be joining this whole
movement and that the people that are
listening to to what the stream live
stream or whatever that are conservative
might actually agree with a lot of us
because you all seem to think that we're
antica I mean who hears Pro capitalism
movie is pro-capitalist alright that's a
lot of hands